que penses tu de la zététique aider
youtuber sceptiques qui parle justement
un petit peu dans cette optique
complètement ya la zététique et il ya
les youtuber qui font les et éthiques
ces deux choses distinctes oui c'est
éthique et hausse c'est je cherche tout
entendu je ne crois pas une chose
simplement parce qu'elle est affirmé
donc c'est la mise en place du doute
méthodique
c'est la démarche sceptiques alors là
encore il ya là qu'ils vont dire oui
mais attention le scepticisme antique ce
n'est pas le scepticisme cartésien on
s'en fout c'est juste de dire que ce
n'est pas parce qu'une chose est dénoncé
comme une vérité qu'elle est vrai et ça
vaut pour j'allais dire de l'individu à
l'officialité qualité et puis il ya la
mise en application de cette méthode
première chose si on applique cette
méthode de mise en doute de ce qui est
affirmé j'estime que le devoir qui
accompagne ce principe c'est de le
mettre en pratique avait envers toute
personne qui affirme quelque chose et
non pas envers certaines catégories de
personnes ou certains groupes de
personnes dont on voudra montrer
qu'elles ont tort parce qu'elles
appartiennent à tel camp idéologique
pour ensuite s'épargner d'avoir à
contredire les affirmations d'un autre
camp idéologique j'apporterai du crédit
aux youtuber qui font la zététique quand
ils produiront à l'égard du gouvernement
les mêmes critiques que celle qu'ils
produisent envers les complotistes
premièrement parce que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire ce ne sont pas les
complotistes qui exerce le pouvoir en
france
alors c'est très bien c'est très
pratique les complotistes parce que ça
permet d'avoir une cible sur laquelle on
peut taper tout en se faisant passer
comme étant du camp du bien du camp du
progrès du camp de la vérité moi j'ai
fait une vidéo sur une ancienne chaîne
qui s'appelait sur le conspirationniste
mais en gros le propos de cette vidéo
dont je signe chaque mot c'est de dire
que le le conspirationnisme est d'abord
une création linguistique qui sert à
discréditer tout discours de remise en
cause de l'officialité
c'est ce qu'on appelle un fourre-tout un
fourre-tout intellectuelle c'est à dire
que dans la catégorie complotistes on va
te mettre celui qui pense que la terre
est plate et que la nasa nous cache le
fait que la terre est plate et on va te
mettre celui qui remet en cause les
motivations réelles du gouvernement
américain pour intervenir en irak en
2002 ou en mots et en 2002 je crois
on va te mettre dans le même lot les
personnes qui considèrent que nous
sommes dirigés par des entités de
reptilien et ceux qui pensent que le
pass sanitaire correspondait à un agenda
politique
du gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois et
ben moi je trouve que cette cet
apparentement pour ne pas dire cet
amalgame
il est non seulement douteux mais il est
aussi malhonnête
quand je dis malhonnête je pèse mes mots
c'est insulter mon intelligence que de
me faire croire qu'on ne voit pas la
différence entre ces différents modes de
complotisme et me faire croire que parce
que je suis sceptique quant à la
bienveillance du gouvernement nous
impose et 1 passe au nom de notre
sécurité sanitaire me faire croire que
ça ce serait peu ou prou comparable
parce que c'est le même mot peu ou prou
comparable avec le fait de considérer
que la terre est plate
nous nous sommes dirigés par des
reptiliens je considère que c'est de la
malhonnêteté je sais qu'il y a des et
éthicien qui d'ailleurs ne se proclame
pas des éthiciens mais qui se proclame
tout simplement des chercheurs des
personnes qui étudient des sujets des
enquêteurs et qui malgré toutes leurs
recherches et toute leur science dans le
domaine qu'ils ont étudiés ne se
permettent pas
de faire des diagnostics psychologique
des gens qui ont des croyances sur ce
sujet ils ont une modestie une humilité
qui est d'ailleurs le résultat direct de
leur immersion dans le milieu qui l'ont
étudié qui fait qu' il ne s'autorise pas
à juger ces gens et à les mépriser voilà
et dès lors que tu commences à mépriser
des gens au nom de leurs croyances au
nom de leurs réflexes
psychologique et de leur comportement
est bien pour moi tu n'es plus un et
éthicien en réalité tu es un petit juge
morale un petit prédicateur prédicateur
de la rationalité qui obéissent
exactement aux mêmes mécanismes que
n'importe quelle secte religieuse c'est
à dire le dégoût le dénigrement de tout
ce qui ne correspond pas à la ligne
c'est à dire la pensée mécanique ce que
l'appel à penser les cas nick c'est la
pensée qui ne cherche plus à comprendre
ce qui nous est dit mais simplement à se
dire tiens comment je vais pouvoir
contrer ce qui met 10 à partir de ce que
j'ai bien appris voilà le sectarisme
pour moi c'est j'ai bien appris ma
petite leçon et je vais le ressortir à
chaque fois que je suis confronté à une
situation où à une croyance qui n'est
pas la mienne voilà c'est vraiment dur
c'est en tout cas pour certains du
dessus bord les bleus je pars je pense
aux plus connus youtuber sceptiques les
plus connus je pense pas que ça soit du
mépris vis-à-vis par exemple des gens
qui croient à la terre plate j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait c'est plus leur
montrer que non la terre n'est pas plate
essayer de de ne plus penser ça il
l'aimé il les méprise pas pour autant la
boisson que leurs vidéos savent que toi
les aider à comprendre que la terre
n'est pas plate non
[Musique]
alors tu penses qu'elle mangeait
développer un bénéfice de demel je vais
développer mais je crois être le dîner
de cons madame dîner de cons il ya un
mépris dans le sens où les vidéos de ces
sceptiques auquel on pense ne s'adresse
pas aux ne s'adresse pas aux gens qui
croient alors il y aussi ce problème que
l'adresse aux gens qui sont d'accord
avec les celtiques et qui veulent
montrer à quel point c'est ridicule de
croire besoin ça c'est un problème ça
c'est sûr que non mais les gens là de
masse font la démarche de cliquer sur
une vidéo évidemment sont pas déjà le
même public que ceux qui croient à la
tension apparente il va pas amener
quelqu'un à remettre en cause une
croyance que tu estimes fausse
en lui expliquant que cette croyance est
au mieux mais si tu demandes infondées
au pire stupide ça n'a aucun sens si tu
te situes dément pas un + b que
aucun aucun contrat lui mais le a plus
baissé et on a plus b à toi c'est à dire
que l'os et scientifique royan semaines
mais qui te dis que les gens sont
sensibles aux scientifiques factuel
attend dans ce cas là on peut plus mais
tu ne t'es jamais retourné la situation
était redouté août a été obligé
d'exprimer expliquer ce qui te semble
être d évidence aux yeux de gens qui
pour qui ça n'était pas
ouais mais là c'est quand même de trucs
scientifique je veux dire aux des kids
qui les styles des sciences on décide
qu'on fait confiance dans la science
mais attends absolvent bien je déconne
pas là tu es en train de te en train de
suggérer que si on ne croit pas dans la
science on est exclu c'est en tu veux le
tout venant témoigner ton rire je peux
d'exclus torts il est le témoin de ce
que je suis en train de dire c'est à
dire que comment tu pars du principe que
parce que des gens ne vont pas se fier à
la science ça sert à rien c'est foutu
mais est ce que tu penses que c'était
foutu j'ai dit justement que c'est grâce
à la proche objectif des mathématiques
et des sciences que tu peux entre
guillemets faire changer d'avis personne
n'en croit là mais jamais de la vie bah
comment elle peut contredire que de plus
de en commençant par lui dire que si
elle ne croit pas dans la science
c'est peut-être qu'elle a des raisons à
elle de ne pas y croire et qu'il faut
commencer par ça pourquoi cas pas
confiance dans la science avant de dire
tu crois dans la terre plate pourquoi tu
ne crois pas dans la nasa pourquoi tu
crois qu'on te ment est ce que tu penses
pas que c'est le fond du problème
pourquoi penses-tu compte mans c'est
comme quand tu pars du principe que
celui qui n'y croit pas n'a pas eu accès
à l'information
mais à quelle heure est-ce que les gens
n'ont pas accès aux informations c'est
ce que quand tu leur mets une
information ils vont identifier
certaines informations comme venant du
camp dans lequel ils n'ont pas confiance
et donc tu peux dire tout ce que tu veux
derrière tu parle au nom de la science
ils ont pas confiance à la science à
quoi ça sert tu vas rien convaincre du
tout quelqu'un qui tu n'as pas confiance
tu vas pas l'écouter pourquoi tout à
coup les sceptiques se ferait entendre
aux yeux des croyants en employant
exactement les mêmes méthodes que ce qui
a provoqué la défiance des gens à la
base donc je pense que youtube
nous servent strictement à lycéens
vassaux sortons renforcés eux-mêmes bien
sûr les trucages et en public évidemment
qui ne sont pas pour le coup d'état des
cas particuliers bien sûr mais oui bien
sûr mais comme on le fait tous on
renforce toujours ceux qui sont nos
propres convictions ses traits
sociologie de dire ça a été étudiée
mille fois mais là le fait de dire ça je
vais passer pour quelqu'un qui prétend
avoir voilà décrypter en une phrase le
principe mais c'est le principe même de
tous les courants idéologiques sur
youtube c'est de ces lotos renforcement
et l'auto consolidation bien entendu
mais c'est pas cependant qu'il invente
ça évidemment
évidemment parce que sinon on se
mettrait un peu en danger on irait
sincèrement pas pour la forme parce que
ça ça existe je donne la parole à des
gens croyant parce que machin et je vais
les je vais tenter de la faire
comprendre que leur mode de raisonnement
n'est pas le bon et qu'est ce qu'on a on
a des gens qui explique leur croyance et
encore cela des gens qui vivent on ne
sait pas ce que dit la science on arrive
à ce que tu disais ah ben ça je suis
désolé je te prends un exemple mais
personne n'en a rien à [ __ ] puisque la
science c'est ce vis-à-vis de quoi elle
est méfiante donc on prend la personne
pour eux pour une enfant dire là en fait
mon petit enfant 2 e 30 ans tu n'as pas
compris en fait il ya des gens qui
s'appellent des scientifiques qui sont
payés par le gouvernement par l'état
alors je vais t'expliquer pourquoi tu as
tort en fait c'est parce qu'il existe
des gens qui sont payés pour produire la
connaissance pas comme toi
et toi et toi ton rôle c'est de
comprendre que ces gens là ils savent de
quoi ils parlent et pas toi donc il faut
que tu les écoutes voilà tu vois c'est
ça c'est évidemment qu'enfin je
caricature mais c'est exactement comme
ça que c'est perçu et ne pas s'en rendre
compte c'est passé complètement à côté
de la démarche qui consiste à vouloir
diffuser l'esprit critique c'est comme
si tu disais que voltaire avait voulu
faire prendre conscience à l'église que
l'église fait voix à l'époque que
l'église se tromper dans sa manière de
pratiquer la religion
que veulent ils n'étaient pas là pour
faire prendre conscience à l'église de
quoi que ce soit il avait été là pour
dire église écrasons l'infâme on va vous
écraser c'est une guerre
flea le reste c'est de la décoration
[Musique]